HIMSELFS IN THE NHL.
>> THAT'S WHAT IN.
BELLEMARE.
KULAK PINS IT AND GIVEE.
THEY HAVE THE PUCK ON THE
STICK.
JUST FANS ON IT.
>> HE BROUGHT THE STANLEY CUP
HERE DOWNTOWN OLD MONTRÉAL FOR
THE LEE THE BEST OF THE
LEAGUE.
DROP PASS AND SAVARD.FOR
AND CHIPS DOWN AND
ALMOST LIFTED PAST MCDONAGH.
NOT THE CLEANEST.
GETS IT BYING
PLAYERS.
>> 1-1 TIE HERE NEARLY FIVE
RIGHT OFF THE DRAW.
MIKE HOFFMAN RIPS IT IN.
>> PRETTY SIMPLE PLAY OFF THE
FACE OFF.
HOFFMAN JUST GRABS IT AND
SECOND PERIOD.
AS COLTON UP THE RIGHT SIDE.
FOR CIRELLI. FOR
HIM THERE.
GO BACKHE BODY CHECK.
MONTRÉAL CANADIENS NUMBER 1 INUA
INCLUDING TONIG OFF. COMING ALIA
LITTLE BIT THROUGH THE AGAINST
HELPS HIM FEEL COMFORTABLE.
HE'S HAD EXPERIENCE WITH THOSE
BACK HAND AND
OF VASILEVSKIY.
PEZZETTA ONE GOAL AND TWO POINTS
ON THE GREAT IT.
LEHKONEN RETURN
TEAM.
FAIR CA
CIRELLI.
WRIST SHOT OFF.
MCDONAGH WRIST SHOT.
LEHKONON STEPS
IN..
PERREAULT. THAT DAUPHIN HAS
SCORED IN THE NHL.LORN FOR PERR.
POEHLING BACK TO THE LINE.
HEDMAN JUST HOL TANGLED KEEP IT.
HIT BY
LATE OF THE CHIP